I wanted to get your take on why you
think this is so prevalent on college
campus what do you think the future of
the universities in the United States
looks like Elon Musk and Ben Shapiro
visited the aitz museum it's not the
they visited the site of aitz and then
there is a museum there uh and they
talked a
bit about what has led to this now I
would say push back against some of the
craziness that uh we've been
illustrating lately now the crossover
between you know some of these
rallies on college campuses in favor of
Kamas I mean they unite the the weirdest
coalitions maybe in human history you'll
see lgbtq Flags in favor of Kamas where
of course if an lgbtq person were to be
actually in the Gaza Strip they would no
longer be in the Gaza Strip they would
be dead yes um exactly that that
Coalition is that's like seriously out
of touch
[Laughter]
yeah but it it isn't but it only isn't
out of touch in the sense that there is
a coalitional idea here that basically
basically power structures must be torn
down at all costs and if that means
allying with people who hate me then
I'll Ally with people who hate me and
and the fact that that's grown in fervor
since October 7th really is you know as
I said to me on on a personal level
quite shocking you what do you make of
the future of a West if if the West
continues to embrace that
idea well I I think we really need to to
stop this principle that the the weaker
nor normally weaker party is always
right this is simp not true um if you
are in quotes oppressed or or the weaker
party it doesn't mean you're right um
because if some of those you know we
weaker uh groups want to annihilate you
that does not make them
good we just we have to get rid of the
rule that that if you're weaker you're
automatically good that's that's
obviously makes no sense
um you know you know it often makes
sense whereas like like okay you don't
want to beat up on someone smaller and
weaker than you um but if that if that
smaller group wants to kill you that
they're they're
bad
okay um I mean I'm a big believer in
moral absolutism not moral relativism
there is there's good and bad in the
absolute um and you judge any group or
individual against absolute moral
standards not whether they they're the
So-Cal oppressed or oppressor just on
absolute moral terms are they doing good
things do they want to motor inent
people that's bad it doesn't matter who
they are you would think but the the
pseudo sophisticates on college campus
seem to think differently and so I
wanted to get your take on why you think
this is so prevalent on college campus
what do you think the future of the
universities in the United States looks
like given the fact that entire
universities appear to have been
corrupted by moral relativism and this
sort of perverse ideology do you think
that a wave of change is coming to the
universities do you think that there's
going to be direct hiring out of high
school what is the solution for
universities in the United States as
well as
abroad I think we need to return to what
it where things were or mostly were
which is a focus on on Merit and and it
doesn't matter whether you're a man
woman uh you know what race you are what
beliefs you have what matters is you
know how good are you at your job or or
how what are your skills you know um you
know you could be a three-legged green
Martian uh you know wears a kimono and
drinks YX milk who cares it doesn't
matter you know um it what matters is
like how good is your work that's it
um
that that that's that's the Le that's
the least sort of racist sexist you can
be is just care about the work that
somebody does and not anything else um
that's that's that's what the focus
needs to
be to return to
um yeah you know it's interesting
because Elon for as absolutely brilliant
as he is it's like one of I think his
main skills is saying sort of complex
things in very simple ways like he uses
very simple language there just because
you are the perceived weaker group in
this case the the Palestinians it does
not mean you are good no matter what
your perceived oppression is again
perceived oppression you are not allowed
to burn babies alive and put them into
ovens you are not allowed to rape women
and murder men women and children in in
just the most Unthinkable possible ways
that does not make you good or just but
unfortunately that is what much of the
modern left now believes and then as Ben
points out they created this crazy
Coalition of people LGBT people for
Palestine gays for Palestine which of
course is very different than Palestine
for gays like the you think think about
it if you're a Hamas fighter somewhere
in Gaza right now and you're seeing on
Twitter because they still do have
electricity you're seeing on Twitter
some gender queer weirdo in Berkeley
cheering you on like think how
absolutely hilarious you must think that
is but they thought the left they could
take all of these people they could
remove all of our individuality which is
the most important thing about us that
you have thoughts you have an ability to
ration and think about the world and
reason and then put that into action
they thought they could remove all that
and then just say oh you're Palestinian
so you're oppressed you're queer so
you're oppressed you're black so you're
oppressed and then what are we going to
do we're going to combine all of you
like we're combining a whole bunch of
Transformers into a much more big a much
bigger powerful robot and that will be
the thing that that b basically destroys
the west but because of the sheer
barbarity of October 7th they are
starting to realize that that a lot of
people are seeing through the
nonsense